I once woke up with the worst hangover
and I only had two Advil like it was my
only two ibuprofens it was like gold
dust and I like immediately went to take
it grabbed the glass to the bed it was
straight vodka and I was like shocked
that I was like what to do do I swallow
the Vodka because then I get the Advil
or do I screw it all out what did you do
I ended up drinking it
tequila is the best shot to do on a
night out
I had to hear the shots last night
and I am regretting it you strong
strongly disagree the tequila took the
best shots no but then what is the best
shot I'm partial to a Jager Bomb oh
bring it because you got you know you
get the kick of the Red Bull there oh
I'm gonna say it gets the job done you
like to kill yeah I'm not thinking about
like the morning after I don't actually
love tequila like I don't love it I
don't love tequila either I just mean it
like it works it does work it does work
but serves as a Jacob yes but the best
shot is in Australia and excuse my
language it's called a wet shop okay and
it is the most delicious shot it like it
has no one's mad about having a [__]
shot it's mainly vodka and then topped
up with peach schnapps a bit of
cranberry juice and a squeeze of lime no
it's delicious
the word schnapps just brings up like
too many memories oh should I get a
napkin or something oh yeah
those shots sounds amazing they're so
good snaps so much I was um extremely
awkward when I first ordered one in
America though did they know what it was
no I just yelled the words
I did that once okay oh I did my I asked
my friend for water and he handed me a
cup of nice just took it down and it was
all vodka I once woke up with the worst
hangover and I only had two Advil like
it was my only two Ibuprofen so they
were like it was like gold dust and I
like immediately went to take it grabbed
the glass to the bed it was straight
vodka and I was like shocked I was like
what to do do I swallow the Vodka
because then I get the Advil or do I
screw it all out what did you do I ended
up drinking it because they just can't
talk each other out nothing happened The
Hangover did not improve hair of the
dark does that work doesn't work on me
you ever do that it doesn't work on me
yeah I I would never try it my Gateway
drink on a hangover is a shandy which I
don't think it's an American thing but
that's yeah I don't even know I'm trying
to figure out what that is it's half
beer half lemonade but not lemonade as
in like Sprite in America oh
hardcore no it's nice it's like sweet
and easy and you're getting a bit of
beer and it's just it's your way back
you shouldn't make an Instagram account
for your pet oh thank you disagree with
that I feel like that's the best usage
of an Instagram you've got a cute hat
yeah I would love to see you your videos
of a cute pet I think animal videos and
pictures are the best and highest
purpose of Instagram
would you ever make one for your own
pets though no uh no it's a who is the
time yeah really I'm too busy scrolling
and looking it up yeah I'm looking at
everyone else's pets do you follow any
pets yes I I follow a uh um hazel who's
a pig oh cute Hazel the pig I follow
this like little hamster that that owner
puts like tiny shoes on it and it's so
funny
I would rather go to a giant blowout
party than have a slumber party night in
well slumber party makes it sound like
you could have your friends there too so
is it like your friends are at home with
you yeah or just you're home alone so
you've got like probably a couple of
girlfriends with some wine oh
I would rather go out to the party than
stay in with girls and drink wine yeah
that's strongly yeah I mean I I heard
the word and I was gonna go this way but
now that all my girlfriends are there
drinking wine I'm gonna and you're in
comedy club and I'm in comfy clothes yes
do you think sometimes you're in a mood
just to go out last night I had a big
night out with the girls it was very fun
because I hadn't seen them in so long
so um got it out of my system I'm ready
for a night in now last night I I was so
tired and it was one of those nights
where like you feel a little bit dead
inside
you know you know when you're not going
to be your best self you might as well
have an idea now I know because no one
wants to be around that I prefer
dressing down to dressing up
dressing down I don't prefer it I'm not
going to strongly disagree with the
statement I just you know I feel like
there's a time and place for everything
yeah right yeah and like there's a time
and place for dressing down yeah I think
I'm I'm in dressing up mode right now we
are both we are so I'm on this side we
have tables on the Press on the Barbie
press tour I mean I'm a little bit
dressed down now as you can tell either
this is maybe the most dressed down I've
been in a month yeah you look very
subdue it's such a muted pink it's more
of a salmon today you're like not trying
Barbie yeah this is
low maintenance Barbie today with all my
Jewels why did I want to call them [__]
shelves they're not cocktails and tell
me what a [__] shell is I don't know
this is replicating out my beach my
beach um
was this custom yeah I love it
cats make better pets than dogs
cats make it better
I'm a dog person I'm a dog person too I
mean I have met friendly cats yeah but
they're the Rarity yeah I have anything
against cats I just love dogs I respect
cats yeah they scare me a little bit
sometimes same my daughter says she's a
cat and I believe her she terrifies me
says that yeah yeah she's a cat wow
that's what she says I'm like I bleep
you when she's in a full-on meltdown all
I have to do is go
and then she stops and meows back that
is so cute so my daughter is a cat and
my son is the top you both have dogs
I've got two dogs I've got two dogs too
I have two golden retrievers I've never
seen your dog over there in New York
they're in L.A oh they're in L.A yeah
but they don't travel like your dogs
yeah well Belle can't travel but
no Bells
yes
it's a waste of time to make the bed
every day
I can't get into bed if it's not me well
that part I agree with so like it'll be
night time and I'll make the bed and
then get in it yes I just I just choose
not to make it and then and then my
husband you hope that right it's gonna
come right okay Tom never does it so
right so you end up doing it about
getting into a main bed yeah getting in
when it's unmade it's just
so many pillows on our bed at the moment
too you know you have to like stack them
anyway we have so many pillows too and
the getting them off at the end like
when you're tired and you're like and it
looks so good but you're also like why
do we have so many pillows I love
working with the person opposite me
easy it has to push that glass right up
here
Cheers Cheers enjoy your water you
should tell someone if they have bad
breath
I you've just gotta you shouldn't say
you have bad breath you just hand them a
little list you're a piece of gum just a
Cuba gum or you take one out pretending
you need some and then you kind of
casually go hey would you like one yeah
yeah I I strongly agree with that I
agree